resume 2019 you know how resume has
always been what here's my job here's
where I work here's my degree here's
this here's that let me tell you what
impresses me I'm sitting there hiring
different CFOs and six CFOs are sitting
there giving me their pitch the guy at
the end says the following to me he says
by the way I watched some of your videos
well I'm here to tell you there's seven
sign there you're going to be successful
in life I just want you to know just
last week I ran the mile in five minutes
and 42 seconds as he did what he said I
ran a mile last week in five minutes and
42 seconds and I'm 46 years old
I said you got to be kidding me no I
made a note of it that's stuck with me
when I stepped away why I thought about
his health condition stamina energy to
be able to last long what does this mean
to you if I am applying anywhere today
and I'm posting my resume I'm gonna tell
you what I'm posting if I've traveled
the world I'm letting you know I've
traveled the world because I've seen
culture and I'm gonna explain to you
that I know how to deal with different
cultures if I have contacts the right
contact I'm gonna put the five contacts
that I have in high places direct
contact cell phone that I have a
relationship with influence if I have a
certain influence where my following I'm
gonna put on my resume 62,000 people
follow me on Instagram you know ninety
three thousand people follow me on
Facebook I have 17 thousand followers on
Twitter and their main niche is the
following five words I'm gonna put the
books out read here's a top five books
I've read in business I'm gonna write it
these are the top 10 books average I'm
gonna sit and say this guy's read these
books yes Wow I asked you about the book
you know about the book I'm impressed
more than your degree I'm impressed the
books you've read your credit score I
got a 793 credit score honey I have a
793 credit score credibility discipline
your hell I ran a marathon three weeks
ago really which one boston marathon
26.2 miles you ran it yes I did an
Ironman you know I wonder CrossFit
whatever whatever for the state of Texas
I'm impressed
those things today matter on your resume
maybe not 20 years ago today they do I
learned how you view resume
you
[Music]